[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition du 7 8 les invités ravis de vous
retrouver voici le sommaire de ce jeudi
8 juin 2017
benoît hamon candidat à sa propre
réélection dans la 11e circonscription
des yvelines après un premier tour à
l'élection présidentielle où il n'a
récolté que 6 % des voix socialistes
souhaitent relancer la dynamique et
surtout prouver que la gauche existe
toujours
championnat seniors d'improvisation
organisé par l'as lydie la ligue
départementale d'improvisation des
yvelines de nombreux participants pour
des matchs d'improvisation dans le plus
pur respect des règles de
l'improvisation théâtrale arbitre
maillot à championnat dans la bonne
humeur pour une grande finale qui aura
lieu samedi et tout de suite de la
politique avec benoît mme fort de sa
notoriété acquise pendant la
présidentielle le candidat malheureux à
l'elysée est reparti en campagne dans la
11e circonscription des yvelines où ils
tentent de conserver un siège de député
arraché à la droite en 2012
pour cette campagne législative pour
cette campagne pardon législatives hamon
a abandonné son slogan présidentiel
faire battre le coeur de la france pour
une nouvelle formule ayant valeur de
test
le futur c'est nous nous l'avons
rencontrée lors d'un de ses meetings
mains des médias
fille et un petit peu non je fuis pas je
pense que j'irai d'abord j'ai eu je vous
ai beaucoup fréquenté et quand on aime
bien il faut savoir aussi mettre à
distance pour pouvoir aimer encore
davantage après des fois non mais c'est
parce que je pense que dans cette
circonscription
j'ai besoin aussi de retrouver
l'honnêteté d'une relation avec des
habitants qui se passe de
l'intermédiaire des médias autant d'une
campagne présidentielle les médiations
important autant d'initiatives j'avais
très envie de quelque chose d'un peu
plus brut
sans intermédiaire voilà c'est difficile
vous êtes un qui chantait comme non
l'accueil est bon partout après je sais
lire des résultats électoraux donc si
jolie les résultats électoraux cette
circonscription que j'ai prise à la
droite il ya cinq ans normalement
devrait m'échapper si je regarde
l'accueil qui est celui des habitants de
cette ville trappe de la ville d'un côté
et l'encours de la circonscription il
est bon maintenant moi je suis pas devin
mais de quoi qu'il se passe j'ai une
relation de toute façon extrêmement
riche et intense avec les habitants de
ce territoire qui sont très différents
les uns des autres et voilà moi j'y suis
attaché la gauche a besoin de construire
de dire quelle société elle pourquoi est
ce que les gens votent plus à gauche ou
alors est-ce qu'ils s'en vont c'est que
on dit on veut on est la gauche ne sait
pas très bien ce qu'on défend et moi je
veux bâtir cette nouvelle société avec
d'autres et ça commence par les
élections législatives on voit bien
qu'il va y avoir un démantèlement
méthodique du code du travail et des
protections des salariés
ben moi je me refuse absolument et mais
pas simplement pour dire non à ce que
fait macro mais aussi pour dire quelles
alternatives on lui propose et
l'alternative c'est la reconnaissance
par exemple du grand nocq comme maladie
professionnelle l'alternative c'est
privilégier la réduction du temps de
travail une meilleure articulation entre
le travail que l'on a et sa vie
personnelle plutôt que demain contre un
travail ou votre employeur décide des
conditions dans lesquelles vous serez
licenciés et plus la loi
ça c'est le projet emmanuel d'emmanuel
macro je n'en veux pas mais je ne me
contente pas de dire je n'en veux pas je
veux proposer autre chose pour cela il a
besoin de travailler de s'inspirer pour
partie ce que j'ai fait dans la
présidentielle et donc de dire quelle
nouvelle société nous voulons construire
je crois qu'on aura besoin de députés
pour incarner ce temps vous avez enlevé
le logo du ps devant
fish c'est embarrassant noro journée sur
plein honnêtement s'il y en a sur
certains documents pas sur tous
franchement ça c'est si quelqu'un ignore
que je suis socialiste dans les
circonscriptions où le trouver parce
qu'alors la celui-là faut le mettre sous
cloche
est ce que vous sentez que justement la
réforme du code du travail quelque chose
qui interpelle les gens qui les inquiète
tous n'ont pour l'instant pas encore ce
concept ça vient d'arriver
on se doute bien qu'il va tomber quelque
chose sur le coin de la tête les gens
vont déjà vous payez plus de csg donc ça
ils ont bien compris notamment pour les
retraités mais personne ne sait
exactement ce qu'il y aura dans le
projet donc non encore
c'est un très beau score à tout
[Musique]
pas simplement d'eux
mais oui mais alors là je dis pas que ça
je respecte complètement les candidats
mais je ça m'inquiète pas diviser
présidentielle moi mais bon ça c'est la
caractéristique de notre époque je
voulais vous j'aurais préféré qu'elle
soit uni mai
elle ne l'est pas donc faut-il il faut
encore passer par ce moment de
décomposition avant sans doute de se
reconstruire
bon ben moi je j'essaie de pas
une fois que si je fais la litanie qui
va pas on va tous pleuré j'ai pas envie
de pleurer puis les gens ici connaissent
des difficultés un peu plus dit un peu
plus lourde que la moyenne des gens en
france donc j'ai plutôt envie de
m'intéresser à eux plutôt qu'à les
canaux culture maintenant depuis trois
ans la libye à la ligue d'improvisation
départementale des yvelines organise un
championnat senior donc qui est
aujourd'hui composé de cinq équipes
c'est ça cinq équipes qui joue deux
matchs tout en glaner pour finir par une
finale exceptionnelle qui sera
l'événement concluant de la saison alors
pour cela nous recevons jessica monteiro
vous êtes la trésorière de la libye
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous parler
un petit peu de caisse que la
l'improvisation qu'est ce que cette
ligue d'improvisation
alors la ligue départementale des
yvelines
regroupe depuis vingt plus de 25 ans des
équipes juniors et seniors à travers
tout le département
donc on organise le championnat junior
un senior et d'autres événements dans
les yvelines ou sur paris
donc voila comme vous l'avez dit on à
d'image
l'année conclu par une finale on a eu la
finale des juniors le 22 avril on a eu
une très belle salle et la défaite des
seniors ça ne l'est donc aux prises
telles salles
donc il s'agit de d'une performance
théâtrale
on est sur scène ou un ring comment ça
se passait dans quel dans quel lieu
alors on joue dans une patinoire ce
qu'on reprend les bases du hockey
l'improvisation de bienvenue au québec
donc on a six joueurs par équipe
l'arbite va donner un thème ou une
contrainte que ce soit de forme de fonds
passant par la manière du molière ou
shakespeare un temps on a quelques
secondes pour essayer de définir un peu
ce qu'on va faire et après on monte un
que chaque équipement de sur scène et
après en forment ensemble une histoire
alors donc on est toute l'équipe va
comment dire monter sur scène en même
temps où c'est à tour de rôle il ya des
règles pour tous ça dépend un peu imposé
que toute l'équipe rendre sur scène on
peut imposer deux joueurs un seul après
on peut dire simplement c'est libre et
après l'équipe fait un peu ce qu'elle
veut dans une durée limitée détermine
également par l'arabité larbi détermine
le titre la catégorie le nombre de
joueurs est la durée et après c'est le
public qui vote pour la meilleure
improvisation oui d'abord on a ou n'a
droit des accessoires ou pas larbitre
peut imposer des accessoires on peut
imposer des lieux des accents
c'est l'arbitré qui fait un peu un peu
ce qu'il veut avec les voies alors donc
samedi soir je rappelle à elancourt au
prisme
une finale c'est à dire qu'il ya eu des
épreuves avant il ya eu du coup le
championnat championnat donc avec des
matches tous dans l'année dont chaque
équipe a fait un match à domicile un
match à l'extérieur et apprend du coup
on obtient une affiche donc on a le
dernier match du championnat vendredi
soir pour pouvoir faire la finale le 10
on parle de match c'est du sport ou
c'est du théâtre
c'est un mélange des deux on prend le
jouer ensemble jouent pas vraiment
content on a ce contexte de match avec
les votes les arbitres mais le principal
c'est de jouer ensemble et de s'amuser
principalement en fait on a quand même
besoin de l'équipe adverse
est-ce que seul ça suffit pas c'est ça
il faut on a besoin de l'autre pour
construire quelque chose car avec chacun
ses idées différentes on arrive à en
faire quelque chose d'encore plus grand
et après et les joueurs entre eux façon
assez fair play ils peuvent reconnaître
les bons mots et les bonnes situations
comment ça se passe bah après ils vont
commencer chacun une petite scène dans
leur coin vont se rejoindre vont
rejoindre leurs idées après chacun va
apporter ces petits éléments et faire
avancer l'histoire parfois très loin
c'est pas un skate jeune équipe lui un
sketch du nôtre qui est jugé c'est
réellement prestation l'ensemble qui est
jugé par le public après vote pour l'une
ou l'autre équipe qui aura joué ensemble
alors c'est donc cette finale elle a
lieu à elancourt au prisme une belle
somme mais une salle de 150 personnes
habituellement non joue dans des salles
de 80 85 personnes
là on s'offre un challenge avec une
belle salle de 150 places et j'avoue une
très belle salle et on attend beaucoup
de monde j'imagine bas pour les juniors
on avait 120 personnes on en attendait
pas autant mais on espère faire autant
voire mieux pour les seniors alors
justement vous vous parlez de seniors 2
juniors il ya donc des catégories
différentes on ne peut pas les enfants
les plus jeunes courent dans leur camp
catégorie pardon et jusqu'à quel âge
alors certaines équipes prennent de 13 à
18 ans pour ce qu'on appelle les juniors
après certains rebrodés coupe en
fonction du nom
d'adhérents qu'ils ont après ce qu'on
appelle les seniors ce sont les adultes
c'est à dire dès qu'on a plus 18 ans on
est considéré comme un signe d'accord et
donc il ya des professeurs il ya des
coachs comme on les appelle des
entraîneurs cd coach après ils sont
professionnels ou amateurs selon les
équipes et après chacun coach un peu
avec son expérience on son passif et du
coup on apprend chacun à se dépasser
soi-même on apprend des accents des
catégories des manières de jouer et du
coup voilà après ça donne de belles
oeuvres qu'elles sont là les finalistes
de donc qu'ils vont se rencontrer
alors pour l'instant de sûr on a
l'équipe des bouffons de marly-le-roi et
le match de samedi déterminera qui de
chatou de chatons l'équipe de touche à
tout des deux châteaux où l'équipe de la
liche et du chesnay ira en finale
d'accord et il faut rappeler donc pour
la finale juniors qui était opposé à qui
s'était l'équipe des kiwis n'inonde du
chesnay et l'équipe des gadgets de rueil
malmaison
ils jouaient ensemble et du coup le
trophée a été remporté par les kiwis non
sur une dernière à pro 9 à 8
après une égalité alors oui il a des
points c'est ça et donc il faut
obligatoirement marquer plus de points
n'y a pas d'égalité possible non parce
que la preuve c'est qu'on est des
finales juniors s'est finie sur une
égalité du coup on a dû offrir une
dernière un pro pour les départager
autre chose on connaît l'improvisation
et la ligue d'improvisation avec le
déclic théâtre à trappes
juste un petit mot c'est à peu près
c'est les mêmes activités c'est de
l'improvisation théâtrale
c'est aussi d'improvisation c'est
peut-être un public différent déclic est
plus axé sur tout ce qui est collé
ou lycée nous on est plutôt sur des
associations locales un local qui
prennent tout le monde tous âges de tous
milieux sans distinction de niveau et ça
veut dire que quelqu'un qui n'est pas
acteur peut rentrer dans une troupe
n'importe qui peut rentrer dans une
troupe il suffit de se renseigner de
rejoindre une équipe et après on se
lance dans l'aventuré de l'impro qu'on
ait des connaissances en théâtre
classique ou non introverti à une
extravertie peu importe où l'on peut
faire de l'impro une question
personnelle des bons combien de temps il
s'est même temps moi j'ai beaucoup aimé
ce que j'ai fait beaucoup de théâtre
avant là je suis à ma cinquième année
d'un pro on va un peu bonne sur certains
sujets mais après j'ai mes difficultés
je travaille encore dessus et on est
content de soi après un bon mot de
relance le public rit on sent fier
d'avoir fait rire le public ou par le
public vote pour son équipe on sent fier
dernier mot ligue départementale
ça veut dire qu'il ya quelque chose au
niveau national et ligue nationale il ya
des championnats nationaux par pas
encore il y avait une fédération qui a
tenté de secret qui n'a pas vu le jour
mais après il ya d'autres ligues à
travers les autres départements fera sur
la saône départementale d'accord destiné
qu'à ameuter rojoux remercie beaucoup
donc je rappelle cette finale qui aura
lieu donc le 10 juin de 17h à 19h au
prisme est en cours tout à fait et donc
nous avons également eu l'interview de
benoît hamon réalisé par patrick jacques
de dixmude et donc jessica monteiro
pardon de la libye de la fédération la
limite d'improvisation départementale
des yvelines
merci pour cette finale de la ligue
samedi soir à elancourt c'est la fin de
ce set 8 les invités merci de votre
fidélité replace sur notre site internet
téléphiles 78 points comme et sur notre
application
à bientôt
[Musique]